está cerca de donde todo empezó el
parque que sí que sigue bajo fuerte
resguardo policial hasta el día de hoy
en el edificio a nado lo kultur uno de
los muchos proyectos de osman cábala nos
encontramos con su esposa hay segura que
dice no saber de qué se le acusa a su
marido
francamente no lo sé no lo sé porque mi
marido no está afiliado a ningún partido
organización un movimiento político así
que es bastante extraño bastante extraño
que haya estado entre las rejas durante
cuatro años y medios strange
force for fears absuelto y luego acusado
de nuevo osman cábala se ha convertido
en un símbolo de la implacable
persecución de la justicia turca contra
individuos que son enmarcados como
enemigos de la nación hay segura no le
quedan fuerzas para esperar un veredicto
favorable el viernes
no puedo predecir nada no espero nada y
procuro no esperar nada porque la
esperanza que llevo a la decepción es
devastadora
antes de omán cábala no es el único que
está siendo juzgado por su presunto
papel en las protestas de jesse que
tuvieron lugar aquí en 2013 en la plaza
taksim en total hay 17 coacusados pero
el mecenas es el único que ha pasado los
últimos años entre rejas
entre los otros siete acusados que
siguen en turquía algunos se enfrentan a
penas de entre 15 y 20 años de cárcel
una de ellas la arquitecta muy el ayapel
podría recibir cadena perpetua
es virgen no tengo ni idea de lo que va
a pasar
tal vez me detengan tal vez me absuelvan
tal vez me reúne con mis amigos es un
caso político que depende de
consideraciones que están fuera de mi
alcance porque no soy de políticas
pensando en el asunto que si el caso
cabal a las acusaciones de participación
en golpes de estado y el trato de la
justicia turca en los últimos años es
preocupante en una medida poco habitual
el consejo de europa del que turquía es
miembro fundador habría un procedimiento
de infracción contra ankara